critics charge President Trump is
needlessly antagonizing European allies
with tariffs on their aluminum and steel
the United States and Europe also
disagree on climate change the Iran
nuclear agreement and defense spending
European Commission President
jean-claude Juncker says that each time
he thinks of President Trump he's lost
and he also says quote I do think we
have to reconnect with Russia I'm not
very happy with the state of our
relations diplomats and analysts have
complained of the deterioration of the
u.s. European alliance warning of a
diminished counterweight to Russia and
even providing cover for European firms
to expand their business there we're
seeing I think France especially also
Germany trying to play both sides trying
to play the United States and Russia at
the same time that realization that
Russia is not a reliable economic
partner that it is a security threat to
Europe much more than two United States
has not quite sunk in unfortunately
Russia mostly sells Europe natural
resources and energy work is beginning
on a massive controversial gas pipeline
between Russia and Germany Russia's Nord
Stream 2 would double Russia's gas
export capacity across the Baltic Sea
the United States ambassador to Germany
tells Fox News the administration pushes
European firms and governments to pass
on business with Russia the strategy for
the United States here in Germany and
throughout Europe is really to remind
European businesses just what they're
dealing with when they deal with Russia
ambassador Grinnell points to European
Union figures showing Russian trade with
the EU is down since Russia invaded
Ukraine and seized Crimea from nearly
380 billion dollars in bilateral trade
in 2014 to around 233 billion in 2015
almost 212 billion in 2016 and more than
260 billion dollars last year the
Russian offense and the activities speak
for themselves and many businesses
throughout Europe are very uncomfortable
with that the European Commission
president says that while Europe will
never forget Russia's invasion of
Ukraine and annexation of Crimea it must
work with Russia where it can adding
that the rush of bashing must end